- You know, we can cut
the blood circulation off,
to his brain.
- He's about to cut off the circulation,
to the dude's brain behind him?
- If I could get to these
small intestine points.
- I'm going to rewind and
if he said intestine points,
I'm going to pass out myself,
because he cut the
circulation off to my brain.
- If I could get to these
small intestine points.
(static noises)
- He's squeezing my
guy's Achilles Tendons,
he's saying that's going to cut off,
his intestinal circulation
which then in turn,
will turn off the
circulation to his brain.
- Go try and choke me yo.
I'm gonna press it, one, two, three.
- He's out.
- I held it for three seconds.
- That guy needs an academy award.
Why?
The biggest snob of the year.
Jumping on Lego every day
until I get a girlfriend.
Oh no, not, that's so painful, so sharp.
(shrieking)
His Tarsals, his Calcaneus,
his Plantar Fascia.
- Take some some Viagra
for the game, baby.
You gotta fit that
circulation going right.
A lot of NFL players, at
least in my day took Viagra
because it opens up the blood vessels,
a lot of endurance athletes.
- I don't know what NFL
players are popping Viagra,
before the game, I get why you
would do it after the game.
Viagra and Sildenafil, the
the main ingredient in Viagra,
is a vasodilator, so it
opens up blood vessels.
It was actually initially tested for
and used for pulmonary hypertension,
so high blood pressure in your lungs.
Now the problem is and why I
don't recommend this to people,
you want your body deciding
where blood flow should go.
What you may not realize
is Viagra has side effects,
headaches and visual problems,
are actually 2 of the most common.
- I honestly have no
idea why he does this.
- Who?
- My working theory, is that he's stupid.
- That was adorable.
That was the cutest thing
I've ever seen in my life.
(fast upbeats)
( excited exclaiming)
He 360 finger rolled that
bad boy, wow that was nice.
I have trouble just
shooting a basic layup.
Rain dunks, making it rain.
Oh, is he gonna help her up?
(cheerful tunes)
Did he just do chest
compressions on her leg?
I'm torn.
I'm half ecstatic that this young child,
potentially watched one of my videos
and started doing chest compressions
but also at the same
time, really disappointed.
Why the heck is he doing it on her ankle?
(laughing and thudding noises)
(gasping noises)
It's true, cause kids are
actively trying to figure out,
if they've actually were hurt
and how much something hurts.
So if your child happens
to fall, watch them,
see how they react and
don't automatically jump
and be very upset that they fell
because that can translate
to more fear, more anxiety.
(intense beats)
Is that supposed to be
like roulette on the water?
Cause that's really cool, I would do that.
(screaming and kicking)
Oh no, we're back with this.
The kick is just for effect,
he's not even really kicking.
I feel like this has become a show now.
(screaming and kicking)
I don't know if this video was
filmed after the first video
and after the whole uproar,
from other other doctors including myself,
that he shouldn't be hitting
his students in the face.
He is barely making contact
with their faces, barely.
Before, he was laying them out,
but now when he's hitting their faces,
even like the leg kick, he's
not really putting full force,
I hope the lesson was learned.
Still not ideal, still
hitting them in the face.
People in the comment section,
"But doesn't it make your chin stronger?"
No, it does the opposite.
The more hits you take
to the face, unprotected,
the more likely it is,
that you're going to get
knocked down in the future.
Isn't that crazy?
Okay, face kick, front kick,
front punch, flying punch,
kick, elbow, kick, reverse elbow, slap,
kick, that had to been fake.
(cheerful music)
- Ladies, If I'm ever down and I need CPR,
this is how you do chest
compressions, okay?
- My guy, I know the joke you're making,
but trust me those are not the
chest compressions you want,
if you ever found out.
You want the good ones, you
want Dr. Mike on top of you,
pounding your chest, 2 inches
deep, 100 beats per minute,
potentially breaking ribs
in order to get you help.
(slow intense tunes)
What?
(loud suspenseful tune)
I'm skeptical about this.
Could it be possible?
Yeah, the body's really
good at creating walls,
around foreign substances,
whether we're talking about bacterias
or a piece of glass.
I don't know about that one,
like just the placement of it,
it looks like it's in the
calf, the gastroc moves a lot,
I feel like you would feel it,
especially with the thickness
of that glass piece.
- Vagina steaming.
- No.
(squeaking sound)
First of all, it's not
even vaginal steaming.
It's vulvar steaming.
Vagina is the pathway to your uterus
and your cervix, it's inside.
I don't think they're putting
steam inside of your body,
cause that would burn.
Do you know what needs to be steamed?
Clothes.
- It's a century old treatment.
- Yeah and it should be century old thing,
that we keep centuries away from us.
- It's a facial for your vagina.
- No, it's not though and
the vagina is not your face,
it's different skin.
One is a mucosal membrane, one is skin.
- You sit over a medicinal steam pot.
- What is a medicinal steam pot?
You're just putting names
on a freaking tea kettle.
- Cleanse the vagina and uterus.
- Cleans.
(windows error sounds)
- You like steam, go into a steam room.
This is garbage, this is misinformation.
When you wake up from your nap
and you real realize you're at a doctor.
(upbeats)
- Oh that's the cutest baby ever.
Definitely not my doctor's office,
cause that baby would be stoked to see me,
man what up you know.
If you mix olive oil and lemon,
you will get lemony olive.
Hold on, I didn't even read
the fact that it said sex fact.
I don't know what I'm about to get.
A better result than Viagra.
(confused noise)
What use are you trying
to get from the Viagra?
Like if you're trying to
create a food topping,
that tastes good and you're
putting Viagra on it,
it would be a better result than Viagra.
But if you're trying to get erections,
because you have erectile dysfunction.
No my friends, Viagra is better.
Food.
(laughs)
How does rice make you
shorter, what is that?
And how does corn make you shorter?
None of this makes, do
they explain any of it?
If you ever see me make a video,
titled foods that you shorter,
unsubscribe from my channel.
How to lose 10 pounds in 1 month.
Massage your.
(laughing)
Why did I think this is
gonna be good information.
First of all, massaging your ear lobes?
Cool, I love it, I touch my
own ear lobes all the time,
has nothing to do with weight
loss, but love it nonetheless.
Eat slowly, good advice.
Not weight loss advice, but
good advice nonetheless.
Coffee does contain caffeine,
which is a metabolism upper if you will.
It speeds up your
metabolism to some degree,
which can help you burn calories.
And if you're having black coffee,
you're not adding all
these fatty things to it,
that people do when they
put a caramel, milky,
cheese induced grande macchiato.
Okay, eat in front of the mirror,
is the worst freaking advice ever.
Like that's just some like
self hatred thing, terrible.
I actually read that in
a Cosmo thing one time
and I was like.
(puking noise)
Don't eat out of boredom,
good piece of advice.
Avoid eating while distracted,
cause it's very easy to binge
eat while you're distracted,
cause then you're not
in tune with how full,
you actually are.
(fast upbeats)
Oh, that's dangerous, the
fact that he can touch it.
Wow that's really dangerous.
♪ I want to say something but ♪
- Oh, this is fun.
♪ I want to say something
but you are all that I see ♪
- It is true.
That's probably my favorite
one, the ball and socket joint.
So sutures are what's inside your cranium,
that they don't actually have
a great amount of movement,
they can have a small, tiny amount.
Maybe you won't even feel
the amount of movement,
that those sutures have.
- Michael, I'm sick.
- It's Dr. Michael to you.
- I got a prescription from doctor,
can you go and get it for me?
- Sure.
- So doctor's prescription is,
for headache Louis Vuitton purse,
for sore throat, Cartier bracelet,
for fever, Jimmy Choo heels.
- I'm not going to lie.
I went on a date and somehow
we ended up in the mall,
cause I think I needed to get
a gift for whosever birthday,
we were going to, or an
event that we were going to.
During ringing the stuff up,
for the event that I was going to
and I was bringing this person as my date,
this was our second date maybe.
She looked at me and she goes,
(russian speech)
which means in Russian,
"how about a purse for me?"
I vomited in my mouth.
Oh no, Newf, is that a Newf?
- But if I'm cold, you're
cold, you got to come in.
- I love when people
try and tell dog owners,
that their dogs are uncomfortable,
when they have no idea any
information about that dog.
I was walking with bear
and I'm walking around
and I'm training him
and bear loves to get spanked on his butt.
(whipping sounds) Like when
I say he's been a good boy,
like I spank him on his
butt as a congratulations
and he gets all excited
and he wants to jump on me,
that's like his version of play.
And some lady comes out
to me on the street,
I'm assuming her middle name was Karen
and she says, "sir, please
don't hit your dog."
And I was like, "thank you."
(patting noises)
You love getting spanked.
(static noise)
- A 73 year old Algerian woman
presented to an emergency,
with abdominal pain.
They did studies of her
abdomen and found this.
She had a Lithopedion, this is a fetus,
who passed away 35 years earlier
and weighed 4.5 kilograms
and became calcified in her abdomen.
- This is insanely rare.
This would only happen
with an ectopic pregnancy.
If the fetus is in the abdomen
and then the baby dies,
because that's not a
hospitable environment
and the patient didn't know
that they were pregnant,
that baby almost gets treated,
as a foreign substance by the body.
It starts walling it off
much like it does an abscess
or any other foreign
substance for that matter.
It creates scar tissue,
fibrotic tissue surrounding it,
calcifications and like,
remember we're scanning everyone
and everyone these days
in the emergency rooms
and this is not happening
regularly by any means.
- Liver king here.
Welcome back to another Saturday dinner,
here's what we're having for
breakfast, lunch and dinner.
We're having liver,
we've got about 3 or 4 ounces of liver.
We got our bone marrow,
so we've got a fresh piece of femur,
we're just going to scoop that marrow out.
- All right, 2 important things here.
Liver, one of its other names
is nature's multivitamin,
cause there are a lot of minerals
and vitamins found in the liver.
There's high amounts of, I
believe vitamin A in liver.
Vitamin A is one of the
fat soluble vitamins, DEKA
and fat soluble vitamins are not ones,
that can be excreted in your urine
and can actually be
stored in your fat stores.
Which means that it's very easy
to overdo it with vitamin A,
especially with a huge amounts
that are found in liver.
Bone marrow contains a
compound called Adiponectin,
which actually has been linked
to lower rates of diabetes
and cardiovascular disease.
There's a lot of good vitamins
and minerals in there as well,
glucosamine for joint health
and while the evidence
on that, isn't perfect,
if you're getting the natural way,
to me it's better than the supplement way.
- Liver king concoction.
- I want to know what's in
the Liver King concoction.
- Round a couple patties today.
- I hope he's not eating
all those patties,
that's a lot of meat.
- All these patties are for me.
Some of you guys think I
don't eat all this food,
I eat every single patty,
I eat every single fry.
- That's a lot of food.
Caloric intake has got to be huge.
I don't know how much exercise he's doing,
it's probably a lot.
I also don't know if he's supplementing,
with any kind of exogenous hormones,
not making any presumptions
here, but it's possible,
especially when you're eating
huge amounts like this.
It's very, very interesting.
(intense hiphop beats)
That's a good exercise.
My man is not only doing a farmer's walk,
with heavy kettle bells but
he's doing it in the water,
with added water
resistance, good exercise.
- It says cell phone reception goes here
and by here that really
means this Faraday cage
and that Faraday cage
is going to make sure,
to block all the EMFs.
- This EMF thing has
been going around TikTok.
People being very much
afraid of low level EMF.
What we've seen is if you
have high levels of exposure,
way high, industrial levels of
exposure, it is problematic,
but low levels don't show
any short term danger,
to the human body.
When we do long term studies,
there's been some inconclusive results,
where there's been some
weak studies that show,
like maybe there's some
tie now cause and effect
but a potential tie that it could exist.
There's so many risks
in our everyday lives,
we have to pick and choose our battles
and if I was to have a
conversation with my patient,
about whether or not EMF
should take a central place,
in their life of risk determination,
I would probably say no.
There's other things
where we can make changes
and have bigger wins and
better risk reduction,
than talking about EMF.
- We have a hard shell
high hyperbaric chamber.
We pump in pure medical grade O2
- This is really interesting
cause based on zoning laws
and how these things can explode,
only certified facilities like hospitals
and places where you have to
have a certain distance away,
from other commercial facilities
and residential facilities I believe,
that you're allowed to have one of these.
When it comes to hyperbaric
treatments though,
there's a lot of misinformation out there,
of people claiming that
it cures everything,
from cancer to Lyme disease
to Alzheimer's disease,
which is complete poo poo.
It's never been proven to
do any of those things.
In fact, here's a list of the things,
that it's actually been
proven to help with.
And we use in our
hospitals every single day.
- We have our cold plunge,
there's pine needles in here,
there are leaves in here,
there's stuff in here,
that you would probably say,
"you should probably
clean your cold plunge."
But this is all earth,
this is all stuff that's going to help.
- Yeah. There's nothing wrong
with having leaves in your cold plunge,
These were painful TikToks,
these are painful memes.
Click here to check that out.
As always to happy and healthy.
And let's watch at some
of these memes together,
they're really funny and painful.
(upbeat music)